evil as a programmer mmm
Технічна допомога Кахуни одним із найбільших
досягнень у цій сфері була,
звичайно, макроекономічна стабілізація,
була дуже успішна банківська реформа,
в Україні була проведена успішна реформа державних закупівель,
і коли ми
спілкувалися з українським бізнесом, ми
чули, що справді в  у багатьох сферах
діловий та інвестиційний клімат
покращується, важливо
розуміти, що зовнішній інвестиційний
план і те, що з нього
вийде, все це буде доповнювати
те, що Європейський Союз вже робить в
Україні, і, наприклад, якщо ви візьмете зараз
щороку Європейський Союз інвестує близько 250
мільйонів євро в українські
реформи